[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mr gay chine très belle chance en tout
cas une belle anecdote ne laissait pas
marqué cette fois çi dans mary à tout
prix
ah oui mais c'est passionnel non c'est
en aidant cissé ben stiller qui se
bloquer sur ses peines c'est une de mes
scènes de films préférés
on vient de le dire merci ouais bof
ah oui qu'est-ce qui vaut donc je
voulais te dire qu'on est avec mais
c'est sur toi toi tu viens d'où alors je
viens d'où je viens et vignes on n'a pas
le dessus c'est d'avignon la réunion
était une fois dans l'année mais écoutez
j'essaie de faire des chroniques que
tous les soirs avec un pakistanais qui
est formidable très bien pakistani
t'emmerde à lire le prompteur enfin ça
marche pas donc on va le faire a lancé
sa valeur faut que j'embrasse mon chéri
du vient du fait que ça comme ça arrive
surtout de série l'a fait au compteur
est allé vois la magnifique bravo en
tout cas à l'arrivée à l'arrivée de
gilles verdez il ya six ans vous
rappeler c'était pas le grand amour
entre jean michel et gilles vesco
plusieurs c'est pas terrible effective
avec le jeu du doubs beach où je sais
pas tu connaissais ce jeu est ce que
vous rappelleront l'intention de
dérouler les anciens du temps vous avez
grillé la chute c'est magnifique j'ai
pas dit qui j'ai pas dit qu'elle est
d'accord et donc le jeu du beach ou en
fait effectivement c'est en hommage au
film plein de l'actionnaire et vous
allez comprendre pourquoi ce jour là
jean michel a encore plus détesté gilles
verdez en repart en 2014 merguez
il n'aura faire que tu es le double tube
quiz c'est parti alors cyril pose des
questions si on répond mal doit manger
un double choo à quel étage se situent
les bureaux de l'association sos
détresse amitié à l'épaule 7e les bons
morceaux bon manifestement le goût n'a
pas l'air de choquer jean-michel mais ça
va changer quand il va voir le secret de
fabrication
l ouverture fin du jeu vous montrer
comment le préfet les doux beach ou un
an
regardez
[Applaudissements]
on attend de voir jean michel gillet
très propre il aimait part de cet
endroit la personne ça me dérange pas du
tout ah bon et là tout de suite
maintenant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non je roule un nom alors qui est
choisissez vous pouvez choisir n'est pas
bon alors on a vu que jean-michel ce
délai que s'est excusé laissez pas
nocive inquiétez pas plus qu'ils disent
je pense qu'on vend donc il se délecter
donc des essais de gilles verdez qui
encore pire que l'épreuve de willy
rovelli dans fort boyard et donc deux
jours après le double gate jean-michel
va profiter de la venue d'isabelle
mergault pour se venger cran et vous
allez voir là derrière phoque cyril
hanouna été aussi heureux c'est quand
kenji a gagné the boys ah ouais
kerry vous voulez du chocolat chaud
voyez et mega beaucoup moi je préfère le
saucisson sec
moi j'aimerais bien voir gilbert des
îles gilbert d'elle et voulait pas
parler avec ceux ci dans l'arrière garde
et on va voir ce que ça va faire
regarder aller lui même prenait l'eau
bien avec les éric farro fiction un fake
alors on se demande pourquoi jean michel
a l'air tout content de voir gilles
faire cet exercice de prononciation avec
le stylo et bien la réponse est
dégueulasse vous avez vous parlé avec ce
stylo dans la bouche moyens jean-michel
bas j'ai un petit cadeau pour toi j'ai
tué ma mère d avec ton monte double foot
m'avaient fait bouffer et avait roulé
sous les bras
la vengeance est un plat qui se mange
froid non mais
[Applaudissements]
comme quoi il ya benjamin est vraiment
habitué habitué à beaucoup plus de
torture parce qu'il m'a quand même dit
je pensais qu'il s'était mis dans le cul
ouais ici je pensais bah oui mais tout
le monde pense et je pense qu'il l'a
fait également mon apparentés libye va
se retrouver dans l'instant adéquat
alors j'ai quelque chose on va découvrir
un petit peu ce qui se passe avec
qu'élire notre relation oui parce qu'en
fait elle est devenue aller + dj
maintenant les spécialistes médias ouais
et donc elle pas en plus donc du coup
ils s'exposent à beaucoup plus de classe
à bath et donc ça marche ça bâche un
petit point de mire et vous verrez ya
quelqu'un quand elle a dansé la semaine
dernière antoine qu il ya quelqu'un ici
qui s'est comporté comme un gros
dégueulasse non quelqu'un ici je viens
de lire on sait déjà qui sait écouter un
petit indice lorsque j'ai dit oui au
khédive et d'aurélie a donc décidé l'an
dernier de se réorienter elle est passée
de dj à spécialistes médias et en
devenant ce message mais là forcément on
parle plus forcément on s'expose un peu
plus à vos vannes et qu'elle est donc
devenu votre cible favorite s'en va voir
tout ça en voyageant au pays de kelly
sur ces huit bien maintenant vous
confondez avec les spurs ont compris
alors c'est la première fois de notre
vie que ça passe sur lui par contre est
vous qui allez je vous demande juste un
truc
la boulette vous l'ajoutez vous ne la
manquez pas
moi je voulais être chanteuse chanteuse
longtemps que j'ai pas chanter
d'ailleurs oui mais non vous ne rêvez
pas merci oui je suis fâché mais si non
je l'utilisé pas des mots que vous ne
connaissez pas
bravo pour tout ce que tu fais vraiment
merci je trouve que tu as ta place dans
cette émission c'est pas pour combien de
temps mais tu as ta place
varin
[Applaudissements]
je rappelle moi
si vous nous rejoignez sur ces 8 on est
bien toute la famille est là qu on
s'aime regarder ça se [ __ ] au niveau
ça saute aux yeux tant d'être avec vous
il ya plein de choses qui arrivent ya
jean baptiste guégan qu'elle aille à son
ring de crise il lui je sais pas qui
c'est mais je n'ai pas de pouvoir
sérieux tout le contraire il paraît que
c'est pas un truc et lille et l'oif
oui alors on en bout pour finir on a
donc vu que qu'elle était devenue une
excellente experte médias sauf qu'ici
faut maîtriser et les médias et la danse
sinon ça marche pas c'est heureusement
qu'il y excelle dans le thoër qu et en
revoyant sa danse de la semaine dernière
et doc gynéco j'ai remarqué quelque
chose d'hallucinant qui concerne donc un
chroniqueur assis autour de nous et
franchement c'est pas joli joli c'est
moche très moche
[Applaudissements]
alors au volant cette séquence on
n'avait rien remarqué et bien analyser
le comportement de certains chroniqueurs
donc on abat la maca stasi canalis
vraiment la performance artistique on à
christine kelly qui elle semble ans
alors que jean michel maire
il m'a tranquillement les fesses de quai
regardez comment je la choisis
ce qui peut faire l'arrêt de doc gynéco
brel et brassens
[Applaudissements]
prendre connaissance pas du tout jean
michel maire alors je vous le dis il le
fait très souvent et regarde si les
carreaux et d'en bas je le reconnais il
le fait à chaque fois jean mi ces votes
non mais c'est son passé de carreleur
[Applaudissements]